No,
I just awkwardly walk around the party until I make eye contact with somebody.
Translates on camera.
Like I don't want somebody to say no,
you know,
cuddle party.
From what I've heard,
it's not okay.
This is what Google says.
I got a cuddle party.
Isn't event design with the intention of allowing people to experience nonsexual
group physical intimacy through cuddling?
Yeah.
That's what we're doing today.
That's the way,
yeah.
It's not going to get sexual.
Uh,
but like,
dude,
come on.
It's like a lot of people cuddling.
I Dunno.
All right,
let's do it.
Don't let God,
What's up guys?
I'm a Mario and I'm Paulo.
Our slogan at Jubilee is lived greater.
So we decided to jump on the road trip for the next eight days.
We're going to face our fears,
do things we've never done and meet new people to explore what living greater
actually mean.
This is the living greater series.
Okay.
I think it's this place.
Yeah.
Hello.
Excuse me.
Or we're in the right spot.
This is the area where the workshop and we'll be okay.
And the cuddling,
name,
tags,
snacks,
bathroom at the end of the hall.
And then you said there was like a changing place.
Yeah,
we're about change in the bathroom.
Oh,
by some cute pajamas.
I don't really,
yeah,
I think what is a cuddle party?
For me,
cuddle party was the gift that gave me back the gift of my voice and like I have
my voice taken away at a very early age and as you sit and cuddle party,
then they start sharing about rules and one of the rules is really getting you
to ask permission and get a verbal yes before touching people.
So the whole Kodo party workshop part is about teaching you how to ask for the
things you want and to stop feeling guilty about saying no for the things you
don't.
And then practicing it sounds super powerful.
Yeah.
All right,
well let's do it.
Y'All ready?
Yeah.
Should we do like a cuddle party?
I don't know how to start a cuddle party.
One,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
Come on in.
Come find a place to sit down.
My name is Adam and I'm here because I really love this work.
I imagine a world where the culture is consent.
My question is,
what in the world were you thinking when you decided to come out here tonight?
My name is Dane and I'm here for growth.
My name is Paris,
often openness.
I'm Paulo and I'm here for the experience and I hear for understanding.
Oh beautiful.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Did we get everybody?
Hi,
my name's James.
I guess I'm here to film it.
We're going to invite you for tonight to try on the concept.
What if there's no such thing as rejection and every time that word bubbled up
for you,
what if you replaced it with the word redirection?
So really go ask for the things you want and say no to the things that you
don't,
so you can really have an amazing cuddle party we're got,
okay.
That's the thing.
I don't know what
I'm allowed to ask them and to like,
I don't want somebody to say no.
All right,
I'm going to,
I guess I gotta go for it.
I don't want to like interject like excuse me,
I was on.
All right.
You just have to go with all right here.
Here's the,
here's the challenge for us right now.
Okay.
We both have to go find somebody right now and ask them to do something with us.
Alright.
Right,
right.
Hopefully Paul is the one that gets rejected
and I translates on camera
cause I think we're so accustomed to not want to get rejected or you know that's
the hard part.
Being able to say no,
it's not a defining events and so I have to remind us that we're not defined by
whether someone's yes or no in the new world so that because we are inherently,
what if you are inherently,
I just wish I could like take you around,
but you're my shoulder whispering in my ear and tell me how amazing I've been
thinking of actually using an app,
but what I do,
wow.
You know what I'm going to do?
Oh sorry.
Excuse me.
Would you like to go talk in the color green or I don't know what that room is
called a bit.
Cool.
Well,
I actually have two.
Um,
is that okay if you do?
I like in 10 minutes.
Yeah,
that's fine.
You want me to come back and ask you or come back to it?
Okay,
cool.
Sound good.
I have two grandchildren and I want the world that they live in to be a more
peaceful,
consensual,
loving place where strangers can talk to each other.
Sure.
Hugs.
And we want to leave people with that feeling.
It's like,
yeah,
I want more of this and I want more of this feeling in my life all the time.
It's fun.
It's really fun.
Just cuddling with everyone.
Letting go a little.
I think I still have a little bit of inhibitions,
but I'll start with the slow and they open up their doors and bring down the
walls,
you know?
Uh,
you can definitely give me a back massage.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh good.
Good.
This is the other,
uh,
it's really not about physicality,
you know what I mean?
Like it's,
it's not about what I think that this is attractive because it's about
connection,
right?
So sometimes it can just leave it like eye gazing,
hand holding.
And it's like all of a sudden you really feel good with this.
Can we do eye gazing right now?
Sure.
All right.
Do you mind turning on my last name?
Yeah,
sure.
All right.
Correct.
When I heard cuddle party,
we're going to do this like what is this?
But then coming here and meeting you guys are going through this.
It's,
it's now I understand why people come here now.
I understand why this exists,
why people feel a connection to this,
you know?
Yeah.
I love it so much.
I look at a room and watch and see people connecting and then just like the,
the sweetness of the energy which comes from touch.
He comes from being authentic and really being in your truth.
I think the authenticity that you guys bring in this.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
All right.
I can give you a hug.
Yeah,
thank you.
Look around the circle and all these people that a few hours ago may have been
complete strangers and now we're just strange
cuddle party
every time.
Think can take a room filled full of strangers and you all feel intimate at the
end.
That's beautiful.
Can
you repeat?
Yay.
Okay.
You know that,
uh,
the girl in the pink?
Yeah.
Me and her just had like a,
like a super deep conversation that I really wasn't expecting,
you know,
going into it I thought,
okay,
we're just going to cuddle and like,
that'll be cool.
Like egg
new experience doing that.
But you know,
it just,
it's a setting where you're just can be open with people and vulnerable.
And I just,
I wasn't really expecting that.
Yeah.
I think it gave me a little bit more understanding that have,
you know,
it's not something weird or sexual or something like that.
You know?
It's,
it's much more than that.
it's real human connections and just meeting people and being really like you,
you know,
in front of other people.
I think it's more than just a coddling you.
No,
not definitely do.
Yeah,
definitely.
You want to cut off?
No,
sure.
not sure.
No,
I said not cuddle.
I have the parts.
He know.
I learned that today.
Hey,
hey,
hey.